hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys it's June there's probably a big
balloon in your pocket you've ruined the
surprise I'm getting quite good at this
sorry I'm 34 years old how does it feel
yeah so once again we're going for a
giant balloon I'm quite pleased about it
you know this year we're going to stick
a pro Blends on a camera that is very
sensitive to light so it should be quite
bright in there compared to previous
years where we also had a pro Blends in
a balloon and what you're going to be
doing well last time we did it I was
sort of scubbering inside the balloon
living in there living in there yeah
this time we're using a see-through
balloon to hopefully allow even more
light in yeah so that you can see me
jumping through the balloon from the
outside I'm going to try and make my way
through in front of the camera so in
slo-mo we should see you busting through
the side from the inside of the balloon
that's the plan well we've never filmed
that before let's do it
thank you
it looks like something medical for sure
so this one is nice because we're in
control of when it pops more or less
yeah
hopefully we'll see your face smush
against the side of the balloon before
you come in hopefully hopefully because
the thing is that's difficult for me is
is that it's so low down to the ground
they're like I'm gonna have to commit
fully and like point my face out
I'm gonna break if it doesn't if it
doesn't burst I'm gonna break my neck I
don't think it's strong enough to break
your neck but yeah but like you know
like if I'm running it's it's like a
freight train right it's just there's no
stopping it you're basically gonna have
to deliberately do that thing when
people trip and they just try and not go
down but they end up running like 50
yards before yeah yeah they go like
but I have to like perfectly aim it here
in uh in Arnold Way one of my neighbors
tripped like by his lawn and he ended up
like four houses down before
step in my house
that goes from the lounge to the kitchen
it's like this high right but if you
don't know it's there it can catch you
out now I just like walk over it like
it's nothing but I had this um
electrician come over he's like
it was pretty old
it was like maybe like 60.
and
he
ate it he ate it on that step going to
my kitchen and made it about six feet
stumbling and like went face first into
the floor through the other side of the
kitchen into the conservatory
[Applause]
okay yeah were you there I was there and
I laughed I laughed
and I was like I laughed and went are
you okay like I was like oh nice guy
actually caught Rock he didn't get the
job
didn't get the job
because of that not because of that no
one like can't have people tripping up
in my head you can't handle himself yeah
this is the closest thing we have to a
podcast is is our balloon filling time
yeah well we have nothing to do apart
from just chat on camera while our
balloon fills yeah it's a nice time I
enjoy it where's my angle of attack from
because I wanna I'd rather run from down
there so I can kind of because that's a
bit downhill yeah you know you're saying
you don't want to get a a downhill speed
I don't want to come from downhill
because then it's going to be harder to
get my face to floor level but if I'm
sort of running up the hill then it's a
bit higher than me it's gonna be easier
to get yeah I mean I'll leave that to
you are you nervous about going through
with your face a little bit do you want
to go through with your hands instead I
mean I'll try with my face first of all
face coming through first would be
Supreme in slow-mo if you can see much
yeah now the thing is you have to do all
my settings once I'm in there what
no can you get in there and hold on
hold up I'll just climb in right now
might be able to Wrangle 2 000 out of
this oh
am I in yeah you're in oh I am in
okay hold on yeah
this camera is
enough I need four hands I can hold I
can get I can give you one hand here
hang on
let's do this on my own last time
I was all on my own now yeah it's nice
having you out here actually oh it's
good don't mind that's normal just very
normal okay I might do another zip tie
just to be safe yeah I think we're good
I'm gonna go over there remove my mic
okay
yeah get ready to dive now can you just
press your hand against where you're
coming in yeah pretty good okay I think
I'm ready three two one now
oh
wow
oh my God
you're on that camera I tried to trigger
everything
and I scorpioned it it's so hard my face
stopped and my ass carried on and it
just bent my back the wrong way
and like I I just like I just stopped
suddenly
you absolutely battered me the camera
went yeah
honestly these videos never fail to be
totally dumb and I always like it when
you're laughing and I haven't seen the
footage
[Laughter]
I was still entertaining after 11 years
oh God
[Laughter]
ah oh
it was like I was diving into a pool how
did you not break your head on the
ground on this could have cracked your
neck bit oh look at what you did
she just jiggling everywhere I've
absolutely shoved it there
oh you see the wrinkles in my back
compressed as my ass just Carries On
don't let myself yeah the level of
commitment was through the roof I did
not expect oh no hand in here I thought
you would do like a 60 send you went 110
on the scent oh yeah that was Unreal
[Applause]
you moved the whole balloon over I did
that is top drawer commitment there
absolutely unrivaled looks like every
pool in Tenerife
just a little bit murky
all right here we go you coming in
wow oh my goodness it looks like I've
got Wings you look giant it's like
you're coming down from the oh it must
have been a centimeter away I can't
believe you didn't hit your nose on the
floor if it was you the blue would have
firstly but it popped but secondly if it
hadn't you'd have definitely hit your
nose on the floor
I like that you can see the moment it
smooshes your nose your hair hit first
dense cartilage begins I love the Ripple
too it is cool isn't it
it looks really menacing what's this
like glisteny part I think that's like
water that's on the outside oh yeah
that's what it is I can't believe you
went that far in like look how far into
the balloon you are and it didn't pop oh
my god oh you can see my eyelashes you
might see my shoulder hair against the
against the outside of the balloon that
is mental move the entire balloon and
now I'm feeling the Ripple like the
shock wave has gone all the way around
because I kind of bounced back off the
balloon I'd I could open my eyes and see
what would happen to you after like it
was like it was like I bounced out saw
you getting tossed by the balloon do you
know what it looked like it looked like
in Lord of the Rings you know when those
Orcs are like being born underground
yeah and they're behind the like plastic
you've got awkward yeah
that hurt actually
but yeah I'll pay for your chiropractor
after this cheers usually I'm all for
your commitment I say slightly too much
commitment too much commitment I think
you're over committed but um you know we
all appreciate it filling up a little
bit more just so it's more likely to pop
yeah I just want to get that balloon
tension up a little bit more
um
there's a little device that I've made
uh I found a screw yeah put it through
some tape shoved it in my forehead okay
so a little bit of a unicorn going on
yeah hopefully this is going to
guarantee I think you're getting through
with that you reckon I think you're
going right through there's a little bit
of a washer underneath to give it so it
doesn't like just lose its sort of
rigidity yeah yeah now the good thing
about this is is that if we tried this
10 years ago it wouldn't have worked
because I just didn't have the forehead
real estate I do now
because I got a bit of a recedo I've got
plenty of space for the tape see there's
benefits too there's benefits doing this
for so long yeah exactly so I could do
more now
yeah like a sundial on your own I've
increased the frame rate lovely 3 000
frames a second
let me know when you're gonna go for it
okay
she worked oh
bloody oh the trigger
there was like no resistance there
whatsoever I didn't even need to like
put any effort into that
my little unicorn head worked perfectly
you'd go ahead first uh well you know
after
it's a hard last time scorpioned I felt
oh yeah you can see your hand like
splashing on the grass that's right oh
here it goes wow
your hair being sucked up by the tension
of the water do you see that it's weird
to see like a ceiling on the water that
is so cool yeah it's like a ceiling on
the water like you said it's just like
that it's a good spirit I think 3000 was
all right what is interesting is that
because of the shock waves hitting me
even though it's in slow-mo it looks
like regular speed handheld oh yeah even
though it even like that micro
vibrations they're just rocking the lens
like against the pl man probably it's
like it's like you've just taken the
sides of a pool away and sort of dived
in so now I'm getting here with air
bubbles
oh and now I'm out
[Music]
yeah it's like really trippy and dreamy
look yeah what like this looks massive
because obviously like the scales
everything up it's just me sort of like
re-correcting the camera it's like
whooshing the pro Blends across the
surface it looks massive it looks like
an aerial shot it looks huge doesn't it
looks like a like a water Planet almost
yeah where am I am I there yeah there
you go is that me yeah
oh is that my interaction is like that's
your shoulder oh it's my shoulder you're
still actually completely encased in
water oh weird the surface tension is
mental yeah I can't even see what I
can't tell what like I'm looking at I
just see a foot and like
you slid right up to the camera
whale
[Music]
ah lovely look at that that's what
people were Keen to see it's your fly
open oh no
it is as well no no wait is it is it
like fully it's fully open that is so
open that's the most pictures I've ever
taken of someone's fly down
oh well there we have it another June
and another mildly aching gut from
laughing so I can't believe it's still
funny to me and it's almost like a
different thing each year that's just
cracks me up yeah the funniest thing
I've ever seen yeah I just had to commit
I didn't know how much tension was left
in these that's the issue there's no way
of knowing no I expected I was like oh
she looks full it'll probably burst if I
just fully commit to this now I've got
an aching back you've got an aching gut
and I had to rely on the Old Phillips
Head on My Head well hopefully you
enjoyed that video make sure you set a
reminder for next June where hopefully
we'll have another giant balloon video
and in between we'll put out some other
videos if you're lucky if you're lucky
yeah and here's some of the stuff we've
made in the past that's all still there
go and have a binge
if you want